>>> STUNNING REVELATIONS OUT OF
THE NEW MEMOIR OF FORMER
PRESIDENT TRUMP'S SON-IN-LAW.
IN HIS BOOK "BREAKING HISTORY: A
WHITE HOUSE MEMOIR," JARED
KUSHNER DETAILS CLASHES WITH
STEVE BANNON.
HE DESCRIBES BANNON'S PRESENCE
IN THE WEST WING ADS, QUOTE,
TOXIC.
>> HE SAID SAID THAT BANNON
THREATENED TO, QUOTE, BREAK HIM
IN HALF IF KUSHNER TURNED ON
HIM.
WHITE HOUSE CORRESPONDENT JEREMY
DIAMOND JOINS US NOW.
JEREMY, QUITE AN INSIDE VIEW ALL
OF THE DIVISIONS IN THE TRUMP
WHITE HOUSE.
WHAT ARE WE LEARNING?
>> Reporter: YEAH, IT IS.
WE REPORTED ON SO MANY OF THESE
FIGHTS BETWEEN THE TRUMP TEAM IN
REAL TIME, BUT TO HEAR DIRECTLY
IN KUSHNER IS REMARKABLE.
IN THIS EXCERPT OBTAINED BY OUR
COLLEAGUE KAITLAN COLLINS, JARED
KUSHNER DESCRIBES HIM AS A TOXIC
PRESENCE AND TALKS ABOUT THE
FIGHTS AND THE WAY THE TRUMP
WHITE HOUSE REACTED TO STEVE
BANNON AND LEAKING TO THE PRESS.
KUSHNER DESCRIBES AN EPISODE
WHERE HE URGED STEVE BANNON TO
ESSENTIALLY STOP LEAKING ABOUT
GARY COHN, THE PRESIDENT'S CHIEF
ECONOMIC ADVISER DURING THE
EARLY PART OF HIS TERM IN
OFFICE, AND BANNON ESSENTIALLY
RESPONDED BY CLAIMING THAT GARY
COHN WAS LEAKING ABOUT HIM.
AND THEN HE ISSUED THIS THREAT
TO JARED KUSHNER, AGAIN
ACCORDING TO JARED KUSHNER
SAYING, QUOTE, YOU'RE THE ONE
UNDERMINING THE PRESIDENT'S
AGENDA.
IF YOU GO AGAINST ME I WILL
BREAK YOU IN HALF.
DON'T F WITH ME.
AND GAGAIN THAT IS JARED
KUSHNER'S ACCOUNTING OF THIS.
WE HAVE REACHED TOUT STEVE
BANNON'S SPOKESPERSON AND HAVE
NOT HEARD BACK.
KUSHNER SAID HE WAS WOEFULLY
UNPREPARED FOR THE MEDIA WAR
WITH STEVE BANNON.
THE REALITY WHEN WE THINK ABOUT
IT IS THAT JARED KUSHNER OFTEN
CAME OUT ON TOP IN CLASHES WITH
OTHER OFFICIALS.
WITH STEVE BANNON IN PARTICULAR,
YOU'LL RECALL THAT BANNON WAS
FIRED FROM THE TRUMP WHITE HOUSE
JUST EIGHT MONTHS INTO PRESIDENT
TRUMP'S TERM IN OFFICE.
AND JARED KUSHNER SUBSCRIBES IN
THIS BOOK THE REACTION OF WHITE
HOUSE AIDES AFTER BANNON WAS
FIRED, TALKING ABOUT ONE EPISODE
WHERE STEVEN MILLER JOKED ABOUT
SPLITTING UP BANNON'S
RESPONSIBILITIES AS KUSHNER AND
HOPE HICKS CALLING DIFFERENT
REPORTERS THAT THEY BELIEVED
BANNON WAS LEAKING TO.
BUT AGAIN, ULTIMATELY OFFERING A
REALLY INTERESTING INSIGHT AND
PORTRAYAL OF THOSE FIGHTS INSIDE
THE TRUMP WHITE HOUSE.
AND THIS TIME FROM JARED
KUSHNER'S MOUTH HIMSELF.
NOT SOMETHING WE'VE HEARD HIM
SPEAK ON PUBLICLY BEFORE.
>> JEREMY DIAMOND, THANK YOU SO
MUCH.